how I currently can we predict the
climate consequences of carbon emissions
how big is the uncertainty there's no
simple answer but the uncertainty varies
greatly over the four steps in the
carbon climate chain current emissions
are known with less than fifteen percent
error the uncertainty in future
emissions is immense as it depends on
assumptions about what the world will
look like a century from now how many
people how rich how will they get their
energy how much will they care about
environment a casual look at a 19th
century forecast of the present day
reveals the enormous uncertainty in any
attempt to predict the far future but
the real question is not to passively
predict the future who's the client for
that but better to ask what kind of
future we want and aim their
understanding the implications of our
choices for our children's future and
understanding that our children may well
have very different ideas about the
future they want than we do atmospheric
concentrations are known with very high
accuracy the concentration of co2 in the
atmosphere is known to much better than
1% scientists understand the carbon
budget in great detail fitting together
different pieces of science to Tellico
hear it well understood story about
where carbon comes from where it goes so
the overall uncertainty in predicting
co2 concentrations in say the year 2100
is small about thirty percent if we knew
the emissions perfectly it's much harder
to predict the amount of climate change
for a given increase in carbon dioxide
concentration here the overall
uncertainty is perhaps a factor of two
or even three that is if co2
concentrations are doubled temperatures
might rise anywhere from 1 degrees a
quite small climate change 26 degrees
are really monstrous climate change
though there is better than two-thirds
chance the temperature rise would be
something between one and a half and
four and a half degrees centigrade
finally it's harder still to predict
many of the impacts of climate change on
humans or the natural world predicting
the impact of climate change on regional
productivity of crops like rice or wheat
is answer
enough if we had to assume that
agriculture and technology practice
stays constant that's the one thing we
can be sure it will not do over the next
century farmers will change crop
varieties and practices to adapt to a
changing climate so the uncertainty is
big for all the steps and we're still
the uncertainty cascades from step to
step so can we say anything useful about
the impacts of climate change in 2100
the answer is yes this roulette wheel
illustrates how the future amateurs
might look if we do nothing to restrain
emissions we could get lucky and have
very modest climate change in which many
people might even benefit or with
equally small logs we might get unlucky
and have very rapid climate change that
we've add almost everywhere more likely
the answer would be somewhere in the
middle now this second wheel show the
results of a specific climate policy the
climate changes are much smaller the
probability has shifted to a much better
outcome there's little doubt about which
world we'd rather live in we'd like to
have less chance of damaging climate
change but of course that leaves out the
question of what it costs to cut
emissions and who pays some people argue
that we should ignore climate change
because our models are poor and the
answer to be is huge the uncertainty is
huge but that's not a convincing
argument for inaction uncertainty cuts
both ways reality could be better or
worse than our best guess it's bad
policy to simply ignore the massive
changes implied in the low probability
high impact segment of the roulette
wheel the hard question is not should we
do anything but rather how much should
we do who pays how do we coordinate our
actions around the world to achieve a
shared goal this question has no single
objective answer values and beliefs
enter in a central way in forming your
own answer to that question you have to
figure out your own view on the basic
question how much does climate change
matter how might it affect our lives the
lives of our great-grandchildren and how
does it compare to the
other challenges humanity faces not all
climate changes will be bad for all
people he will and northern latitudes
might benefit as growing seasons
lengthen for our board and crops
industries that want to exploit
resources on the Arctic may benefit from
the nearly ice-free conditions in the
summertime but there is little doubt
than most people and the natural world
will be worse off if climate change is
fast and it's a certainty that of humans
in this century let's co2 concentrations
get to say three times their
pre-industrial value they will deprive
future generations of a chance to enjoy
much of the natural world as it was at
the start of the Industrial Revolution